现在进入我们下一个环节这也是我觉得今年来说也是韩金亮非常高的一个部分我们来聊一聊就是动格他是怎么样去从一个因为他也是从新手开发的成长起来的嘛他是怎么样去在这个过程中他的一些成长的精力以及一些思考OK那当然我觉得就是我们在每一个系列就是每一场在这个系列里面每一场活动我们都会去跟讲师交流的一个问题就是从
每一个讲师都是由新手开发者去成长起来的嘛那我们也很想了解一下动文哥就是在你的这个成长过程中你经历了哪些成长阶段可以给大家讲一讲嘛分享一下你的经验OK其实我从2011年就开始工作了嘛然后到现在有十一二年时间了所以其中其实又是有很多个不同的一个阶段呢我相信那个就是
今天大家那个直播监狱同学可能更关注的是说最开始那个阶段就是呃从新手步入正轨的呃是是怎么样的一个过程对吧然后你进到一个非常熟练的一个一个那个支撑研发的这个这个这个过程我可能重点就围到这个去讲吧我觉得在那个从新手到到一个熟练的开发的过程中我经历过两个层次比较快的一个阶段吧第一个阶段的重点呢我觉得
很关键的就是要尽快去实践因为软件工程在我看来它是一个新闻实践学科你不是在靠书本、靠培训、靠上课这些方案去学的真正最快的方式就是直接到项目里面去做然后你积累的经验都是有用的经验然后真正的编程锻炼能力锻炼的其实是解决实际问题的能力
刷体的能力这个会很不一样然后呢其实最快的就是说你到真实的业务场地中遇到什么问题然后就就学什么技能然后快速就完成第一笔原始经验的一个积累呃分享呀就是说我是在大学期间才开始正儿八经的开始学习编程的之前可能还干过一些别别的事情当然可能还做过一些屏蔽设计什么的
但是我怎麼去快速完成第一個階段原始機能就是加入了學校最大的一個計算機社團那大學期間靠著這個社團它在校外有些關係所以接了非常多的外包項目在練手然後我在大學期間陸續也賺了一萬多塊的項目經費然後因為這些外包項目的經歷的基礎在我還在大三上學期的時候我就已經拿到了開興農產那家公司的實習offer
算是提前一年步入了社会去实习然后都是比我大一届或者毕业的同学跟我一起在实习然后实习一个月之后我就开始拿政治员工的工资了然后就就很快就整个发展速度就非常快那毕业的时候到毕业的时候我已经签了那个offer就是同理人的两倍多了然后这整个的过程其实核心的点就是尽快
因为其实我很早就开始提前做各种的实践各种的产生是各种的准备所以你不要犹豫就到最真实的产生里面更早的部落社会更早的去参与这些实践然后更早的去做真实的项目这个对你会非常有帮助然后这产生的优势它会让你跟同一人会拉开
差距然后这个差距又容易形成正向反馈那你保持这个差距然后越来越大所以这个是第一个阶段我觉得大家最值得关注的点然后到第二个阶段的时候就你原始的那个原始经验那一笔已经积累了差不多了就是你基本上接到各种活可能费劲点你都能够开发好对吧那我在第二个阶段的时候是怎么从干活都能把它给给干下来到把活干到非常好就是成为一个
在比如说编程上面或者架构设计上面有一些自己的思路有一些经验有一些想法的这样的一个工程师那第二个阶段我觉得很重要的一个观念点是你要去选一个成熟的优秀的开源项目也好啊或者反正就是非常成熟的一个项目或者跟着一个很直升的人一起去学就是洁净就是把别人的经验快速的靠比过来附用到你身上那我非常有一段经历啊
我最开始就是还是在开心农场那家公司期间因为那家公司呢当时在做社交游戏嘛大家都还有那个印象那社交游戏里面大量的工作呢都是在干嘛都是在拼那个UI面吧所以当时我记得就很多的同学都很不愿意干这个货那包括我自己也一样就是拼UI面嘛非常枯燥然后游戏没上限我们已经改了五百的UI了然后当时呢我当时会做一件事情就是说
我开始每天晚上下班会写代码写到生液,有时候整个通宵我都在写代码,我在干什么呢?因为我不想做听UI面板这种体力,我觉得它没有技术含量,所以我就尝试的把我之前用过的就是Adobe Flex,它的那套的企业UI框架的方案,一直到游戏上把它简化到游戏上面。
也是因为这个不停的在这上面就产生最后我写出来的Flex Lite那套的游戏行业里面的开源的UI框架并且自己还开发了配套的可涉化编辑器那让这个整个的生产效能提上去了然后大家都不用再去做这种代码去还原这个UI面吧其实跟我现在做的事情有一点点类似的都是在提效这一块的事情然后这段经历呢真的给我带来非常大的一个提升的那个点了主要是说
我做的虽然是说是简化跟移植但是你想办法从头再复刻一套完整的方案那势必推动着我要对这个方案的细节非常深入的了解所以那一两三年里面我就是一直跟这个方案在使课然后遇到一些就是我的方案遇到一些问题的时候我就回头去看它的原码它原来是这样设计的
然后他的架构是这样做的然后原来背后都是有原因期间我其实也会自己会做很多有一些小聪明就觉得你这个设计这些款报应我们你改一下然后那个怎么再优化一下对吧然后但是其实绝大部分自己的那些变动或者是那个大刀寇府的感情最后发现其实原版的那个方案才是最好的但这个是很有价值的这样的一个过程因为你最重要的点就是要在实际问题中不断的碰壁
然后呢有业务需求然后再速度给你告诉你这个方向是错的然后呢你大部分人遇到这个错的时候他就蒙蔽了他不知道我怎么办我也我也没有什么可以参考的那如果你有一个这种正好那个方案是开源的然后他遇到的问题跟你遇到的问题是类似的然后你又可以参考他的研码那这个就是直接的经验的一个一个来源了我觉得说你要再不停的仿佛的这种
這種的碰壁過程中然後又有一個不管是說很資深的人在給你直接闖的經驗還是一個很成熟的開源項目你把它鑽研到非常透那麼它可以給你帶來的提高對架構設計就把編程的代碼寫得非常好這個是有一個非常強的一個推動力的我當時基本上就是靠著研究透幾個成熟的開源項目很好的就培養了這種架構上面的一個直覺
我这里要重点长调的这个东西就是叫做直觉因为你刚毕业那几年你去谈什么架构能力啊编程的设计能力啊我觉得基本上属于是悬起来因为我那个时候的话那个基本上是属于我大概能知道遇到这个问题的时候我大概能知道什么方案或者怎么写会更好当时我讲不出来为什么
但是这个直觉是很有价值的这个直觉可以把你避开非常多的坑你有很多的那个遇到实际的问题就是说因为这个直觉在这里直觉主要是对的那你后面少走非常多的玩弩然后你在一个正确的道路上然后又尝到田头了你会不停的巩固它那你对这个架构的认识就会越来越深然后一直到最后很多年以后你回头再看我不仅知道为什么要这么做了然后我还能讲出来它的
真正的好处是你能够把这经验给分享给变了这个的来源其实就是你一开始就有这样的洁净你可能要花很多年你才能讲得出来但是洁净就是你一开始就去把别人做得好的这个经验把它给复刻过来变成你的一种直觉你虽然没有彻底理解透达但是可以让你扫着很多的弯路那是这样一个阶段我觉得你就不会浪费时间
你的成长曲线就一直是跨于同一轮了这是我可能从新手到熟练手的一个最重要的两个快速成长阶段嘛那再往后的话更多的可能就是考虑你的整个的技术的职业发展它是怎么样的一个一定要有连贯性就像我职业的前半段是在做游戏后段在做短视频但是它其中的技术是显接的完全是显接的散了都是在做图形圈了
然后再有就是说你要不断地去选择有挑战的业务场景来驱动你的技术的一个成长这个可能是后面更长的一个时间里面你怎么还继续保持高速的一个成长曲线但是最最关键的是干毕业的头伤点就是大家成长一个非常非常环境的一个时间把这个节奏一定要用好
谢谢动物哥的分享因为我觉得我们直播间可能有很多都是这种初中级的开发者尤其是可能还有一些高校的学生我觉得你分享的这两个经验应该是对他们有非常大的启发的那对另外那也讲到另外一个点因为其实可能直播间也会有一些可能就是当转管理的一些同学嘛然后其实动物哥现在其实级别已经很高了对但就想问一下就是
比如说从一个普通开发者召唤着这种负责人的角色你当时是怎么去适应的呢说实话说啊就是我在加务腾讯之前呢虽然有经过世家的创业公司也带过几十轮的技术团队但是那个时候创业公司对我的要求更多的还是技术专家要去攻坚难题的这种一个角色所以我一直都是偏向技术线的
然後真正在團體管理方面的快速成長就是騰訊了這個四年多五年的時間裡面然後我覺得是在這個方面上是成長會比較快一些那主要是兩個維度吧我覺得第一個就是怎麼完成講就怎麼完成從這個技術角色到這種管理角色的一個轉換啊兩個維度第一個就是在很像的維度方面呢核心呢你就是要邁過心理上的那個砍就不要限定
自己只是一个研发你要多从用户的角度多从产品的角度去思考很多的事情其实分工并没有那么清晰的边界如果你认为自己只是一个阶段干活的需求都是有一个固定的角色叫产品经济它提给你的那你可能会不太能干得好技术管理的这个工作作为研发的我认为它是有优势的有很多人会认为这是略势就是说你对技术细节的了解会让你
你看不到大局什么之类的然后产品细节上面你设计的不是特别好我觉得不是这样的就是作为研发的优势就是对细节也足够的了解那这个会帮助你在产品上面的决策会烂它的整个功能体验会更符合用户的需要然后会在工程上面接受很多忘录的成本因为我们在合作过程中就很多产品提到需求它从一开始可能就不合理但是
你完全的尊重就是说职业分工就是你是提需求的我是监大的所以我也不去突破这个边界的话其实你会让你下面的团队的同学做败感很强然后做很多重复反攻的工作所以一定是很像在技术管理上一定很像是要去突破心理上的这个坎的就是不要把自己限定成是一个接当干活然后是做技术的
然后你真的往里面深入到细节率跟产品啊跟他们去讨论这些产品啊用户角度的这些问题的时候你会发现其实不一定这些产品经理他们的经验会比你更丰富的就是存用户体验上来说然后第二第二块呢我觉得说对下方面就是你什么就带整个技术团队吧这一块呢我觉得最重要的一个是意识的还是一个意识的一个转变就是
你是一個從一個技術專家你本來的特點是說自己可以把活幹得非常非常好但如果你要變成一個管理的時候最大的轉變是你要也是一個最大的挑戰你要從驅動自己把活幹好變成驅動別人也能把活幹好這是驗證你是不是完成了這個管理轉型的最重要的一個標誌即使是別人他幹的沒有你好這可能是大概率事件
但是也一定要把手头的事情尽可能地分下去否则不管你是再强你最终都会变成团队里面真正的那个平定因为大部分的事情你不插手你就不放心然后他就做不好那整个团队都在等着你插手那作为基础负责人的话你这样其实没有没有对最终的结果去负责所以这样的方式是不好的这是这两个方面的一个
一个思维的转变我们从技术装夹内心往管理他们就转一个很像一个直对下但是总体层面上来讲我觉得技术负责人不应该是会去脱离技术的我从来不认为存在一个存管理的技术负责人因为我始终都是要保持对技术的熟悉度才能做好这份技术管理的工作的
但你前提還是要注意我前面說的也就是只要是別人能做的你就盡可能不要自己做然後要盡可能分出去但是那個一直還是要保持對技術的一個把控對技術的一個追蹤我至今也還是一直都有在攜帶嘛然後只要
那个团队里面没有什么紧急的事情必须说我我就做的时候我就会自己去写一些代码然后你们在Github上的话还是可以看到我很多人一个提交的这个是要一直去保持自己对基础的这个热爱啊还有他的熟悉度大概就这个吧我明白这可能也是动格为什么就是在这么高的级别下还能来参加我们这个就是系列直播活动的一个原因吧
对这个我完全赞同啊其实作为技术负责人可能我们讲可能会有management和leadership这两个概念嘛它其实包含这两个角色一起的管理可能是management是纯管理但是leadership的话我觉得确实像dome跟讲那个点如果在没有很好的技术背景情况下应该是做不好这个角色的你很难去给大家指一些正确的方向嘛对ok好谢谢然后
那因为刚才讲到其实动格你整体其实应该是一个非常就是成长很快因为你说你其实在很多关键时候就已经你先同理人了嘛那我觉得你肯定是有一些高效提升自己的方法的刚才你也其实讲了一些但我们还是想准备专门准备一个问题让你刚刚去调一下这个这个点
前面其实我有提到过我认为计算机业的软件工程都是一门实践学课那最高效的方式其实就是直接上手那那个举例比如说我要学习一门新的语言直接开始找一个有具体功能点的程序开始写就好了
我第一次在开心农场一家公司时期的时候他们给我的那个案例我觉得挺好的直接写一个落实方块然后呢这个游戏我从来也没写过游戏但是就从这个开始上手我就开始查所有的资料文档包括语法的这个文档然后把每个东西都搞完了然后把它跑通了然后那个一做完之后我发现能写的东西就很多了其实就是这样的美门语言呢
其实你不应该是说我去赛门课我还要去看你视频买本书把它全部都给看完每门语言都会有大量的荣誉信息每门的基础账都有大量的荣誉信息但是我们实际在项目中真正能用到的部分永远都是只是一个纸迹的那怎么去确认这个纸迹呢最有效的方式就是直接开始用你用到什么学生吗
然後現在的說說隱形各種的觀光文旦都是非常非常全的你用到什麼學什麼這個是最有效的然後沉澱下來的東西一定是真實需要的能力然後那個比如說你看像我現在好多年一直主力的開發語言都是世界家
但是其实世界上有很多的语言特性我也还是都不清楚的但完全不影响我写如编辑这样的一个项目遇到不懂的新特性的时候我也是现场谷歌一下然后插在文章随时先学随时保持学习我会认为世界家它是一本不太合适新手学习的语言因为它的创始人都有说过世界家是反警凑的语言就反警凑什么意思一个人的人脑装不下
那这个为什么不适合新手学呢就是因为语法特性太多了然后呢就很容易让新手先进去觉得我学了几个比如说模板编程的高级用法自己可能就是大成了我懂得那个STD里面那些酷的一些那个那个那个那个内部原理还是MAP怎么实现呢我就是大成了但实际上呢你你都陷到了语言层面的奇迹营桥里面去了但是真正编程应该断裂的能力
最最重要的是解决实际问题的能力你的抽象能力你能够把实际问题转化成最简洁的代码这个是编程里最有价值的所以我认为最最高效的就是前面强调过的就是立马上手开始做就不用不用想太多然后还有一个高效提升的方法就是这可能也是一个认知的问题大部分人可能
跟大部分人认识可能不太一样我直接说结论我认为智学和乐爱这些因素并不会让你很高效地提高你靠兴趣智学积累下来的东西跟实战实际上还是有非常远的一个距离实战的需要作为程序员我觉得我们唯一能起到真的能够起到作用的一个决策就是不断地去选择有挑战的业务环境让真实的需求驱动你学习成长提高
那我其实跳炒过非常多次了期间也有时不时的有很多就怎么讲基础上的不甘心嘛那比如说我之前在做游戏引擎的时候我想扩展一下我想去做桌面上的一些员生的一些开发方案就可能就把把那个画平台这个引擎给他做了然后呢到我跳到了把视频那个公司的时候我可能业余时间我还会抽出来然后一直想去写那个想做一个新的一个开源项目但是
持续了一段时间之后我发现这个项目根本没办法进行下去这核心就是缺少真实的业务产品驱动就真正优秀的技术架构啊技术设计你看像贴纪这些东西啊如果我不是到了短视频的行业在游戏行里面我永远不会想到我会开发一个这种的东西出来然后我也不会想到比如说那个1.0,2.0,3.0,4.0我会去做那些能力这些能力都是来自哪里呢不是我想出来的优秀的技术架构不是靠
程序员想出来了他其实真正的来源是业务需求就是有挑战的业务需求他会推着你逼着你往这方面去想然后你到时候你就会发现非常幸运啊这些的业务需求挂进来之后我原来都没有往这方面向去想过我为了解决这个业务需求之后我把这个东西知识体系组成了一个网然后设计了一个非常牛逼的价格可以把这几个场景都覆盖掉
如果没有复杂的业务学就推荐一种的话你的技术进步是非常非常小的就几乎可以忽略的一个程度所以你在面试的时候你会发现你简历上面写什么我学过什么东西是没有人看的就是最重要的是你在真正的项目里面用过没有然后呢我们自己能做的有很多事情是把握不了的比如说我的项目能不能
比如我以前做游戏啊那个游戏里面那个发行了之后如果能够火一个游戏我可能这辈子就够了就一个游戏项目你看下大家如果有人待在罗耀那个项目里面你们体会吧集体去买结束的那种感觉就是这样但是这个是可欲不可求嘛你碰不到的我做了那么多的游戏项目一开始职业生涯前半段都是90一色反正全都挂掉了但唯一能够
留在自己身上,其实就是技术能力的提高这是唯一能够控制唯一让技术能力提高而自己不用花乐壳的心思去说我得用什么样的学习方法,什么东西你只要做到一件事情就行了选有挑战的业务环境我每一次套潮我都是在看接下来三年里面差不多都是这个频率接下来三年里面
我是不是把自己放在了一个很有挑战的业务环境里面那只要这个业务环境它的需求是真实的而且挑战还有有足够挑战而且重要性足够高那你不用做惨它一定会逼着你成长的然后你提升就非常的快我觉得这两个是最重要的没有价值我觉得我们在问这个问题的时候东哥还给了一个跳槽的质单可以可以非常好非常好但我觉得
了了现在我觉得大家感觉到其实动格应该是一个非常非常务实的一个一个人所以我在想就是就你的团队这个工程师的文化会是什么样子的我相信直播间很多同学如果是对你的团队感兴趣的话他们也会很想问这个问题我不知道你可以回答一下OK我们团队我们团队整体氛围
如果是对自己做一个评价的话我觉得一个词应该是严谨还是整体是偏向一个严谨团队总体上来说应该可能也是跟我们主要是偏向做底层引擎这一块的技术方向是有关系的我们跟上层可能应用开发的团队最直光的比起来就可能我们代码函数产量上是不如他们的但是因为
大家都在开发世界家,世界家出问题了会相对会难排查一些,而且一出问题都是口外区级别的严重问题。所以我们在内部其实整个团队的编程、氛围都是非常的把问题扼杀在源头的,所以我们在这块都会做得非常非常的认真的。
也会有一系列的我待会会讲一系列的我们会做哪些措施但是整体上的感官来说的话就是大家对我们团队评价可能就是偏向严禁的然后另外这些年大也都了解就是环境的变度很大就是总体来说的话很多团队就直接看了就没了就解散了我们团队相对还是比较稳定的然后多多少少也有一些流动只要是在我们团队呆过的同学
出来总体上都是都都可以这么说是比较抢手的嗯是因为因为有这种严谨的一个编程分隔的那个那个家常在其他团队里面其实你你的那个印通货是在自己身上的就是我在面试所有人的时候其实面试进来的时候很严格就经常我面试挂掉了然后很多其他团队可能被他们给捡走了然后我们进来的门看看就相对比较高然后
我在面试的时候我都会跟大家去说同样的一句话我就说我不指望你一直跟着我干这个也不太现实我自己可能两三天我都会跳个草就这样的但我希望说你跟着我的这几年你在我们团队待过你能够获得技术上的成长这个东西是你唯一能把控住的然后你自己的应通货所有的福利待遇所有的心愁这些东西都会因为这个东西被拔高了
所以你不用去想别的东西,就把这一点弄好就行了。所以我对整个团队的技术上面的把控,还有这个严谨度上面的要求会比较高。那我们在团队里面是怎么去做这些事情呢?
我们对扣的review的要求是挺高的整个团队的所有的代码提交全部都是要扣的review这个可能还是口中一点包括我自己写的代码我也是要让别人去做review的否则都不能合录进去我们做了一整套CICD的流水线就每一个提交它有完整的就能自动工具自动化的东西我们都不会说要能工具检查了全部都能自动化了然后你要跑完我们之前预设的所有的测试
然后你才能够把这个要合进去然后并且一定要有别人去旅游连代码这个是一方面然后呢整体上在我们团队写代码它是要求要有一定的解辟的就是你只是把功能实现这是不够的因为你去下御一个你看PKG发展来五年了它这个方案如果是放在普通一个上场的App用开发队团队里面去它随着业务需求不停地往里面加
可能第二年我猜大部分情况就是已经没办法维护下去了所有东西互强逻辑是冲突的就是你把那个功能开发得很快然后堆进去然后把它实现了跑起来然后你到后期维护基本上就是一大坨的在那就很多东西交错在一起的然后就是把代码写到复杂写到直接刚刚好可以用这就是最简单的写到简单才是最能的一件事情所以我一直要求大家是要把代码写到
不仅是功能能用这个是绝对不够一定要把写到足够简洁然后可以维护然后我们所有模块逻辑都很清晰那比如说有一个功能过来我新加了一个功能你在这个改的过程中你一定要看到周边模块的一些影响那这些模块呢跟你之间的作用是什么呢你加入这个功能之后你又没想过就说我整体上是不是应该还要把别的模块一切重够一下不只是把你的功能做了让它整体看起来更合理一点我们会去做这些方面的一些旅游用甚至一些很细的东西就是
对外暴露的一些接口的命名这个名字起这个单词号还是那个单词号我们话其实日常这跟这写单码的时候这个好像国外有一个大臣说过就是写单码最难的部分是什么就是命名命名是一个很重要的事情能够让你这个东西很容易诡弧很好读那就是我们在命名上也会也会有的非常严格然后
平时呢我们会做一些CR的那个时候呢会暴露出来一些点心的问题比如说昨天我在做CR的时候然后就一个很典型的场景有一个功能呢那个大家实现那个有个同学实现的时候呢他要他有一些特例的那个要判断他就把那个特例的判断呢给他拉平了放到上一层的业务逻辑里面写了很多的EVL是在那里面然后我要告他你这个场景其实更应该说下场下去用多态的方式来实现
那我每个成绩关注的东西就在上层起码是统一的一个然后你调用的一个逻辑接口都是统一一个然后是调用到的具体的籽类它来负责这个异化的行为这样的话你整个的思路就非常清晰就很好维护然后它反映确实这样然后遇到这样的开始的话我一般我们就会把它发到群里面去然后大家一起去看这个代码那个让大部分人知道就是为什么这个东西要这么改然后为什么我是这么想的
然后呢你没有这么想的话但是哪里可能思维上要扭软一下然后我们把这些问题都注意起来那你慢慢去积累这些细节的时候时间长了就会就是架构能力以上你就会写出来很好维护的单嘛这个东西短期内别人可能看不出来有那么强的一个价值但是长期你会形成跟同龄人跟别人数量级上的一个产出的那个差距就真的是不夸张10倍以上的你一个人可以顶10个来
再拿到架构的挑战的问题你都能解决让别人搞不定的这个是非常有价值的一个点然后就是我们团队还有一些文化就是说我们绝大部分的产品需求其实我们团队在过程中因为一直是底层的旧团队很少有产品在给我们直接提取我们绝大部分的产品的需求包括我们这些桌面工具甚至有一些UI都是我自己
我自己在打空的然后UI交互还是什么这些东西然后都是研发主要在提需求的然后我们会坚持让每个同学都去接受那个接触那个一手的用户的真实的需求都会在那个对接你会发现就是包括我自己我时不时的我都会在论坛在QQ群里面在T hub上面去回各种的那个问题因为这件事情非常重要你要去接受一手的用户的需求然后我前面有
提到一个点带没有记得就是这些需求是驱动你基础快速往上走的最直接的一个来源那这些我们团队研发他就自己每个人都平时都会去接触这些需求然后他觉得有价值他就会把这个需求带回来然后并且自己去把它给开发完所以你就会得到这样一个很快速的一个提高的一个动力就是大概就这些吧就我们我们党内公司是吧嗯我们现在讲就是其实一个团队的氛围往往是由这个
就这个团队的文化可能跟这个团队的负责人是有很直接关系的所以我确实听动物哥讲下来就这个团队其实应该是一个能高效成长的团队所以我估计直播间可能应该有很多同学可能对你团队感兴我不知道你们团队现在还有没有抗议之类的
现在整个腾讯都说了好吧 但没关系我觉得未来有机会 未来有机会对 以后还是有机会的我觉得肯定有机会的 大家可以大家都给那个来个贴级的那个github加个start我们发展好了就会有机会了对对对 大家可以就是也可以通过我们右下角的二位马进入我们的交流群然后续
这条线总是在的嘛对吧后续万一有新的机会可能我们也会在这个交流群里面去发出来ok 那这里就讲到另外一个问题啊就是因为我觉得动格肯定是在这个你现在技术的sense都还在嘛就是你所有的这些东西都还在做那其实我们也也是在这个音视频这个领域里面吧就是对于这个开发者我不知道就是从你的角度有对大家有没有一些什么样的指引呢对就是
帮助大家去更好的去做后续的发展因为我觉得这个这些音视频的开发者可能尤其是初中级的那后续能看到我们这个访谈的话对他们也是很有帮助的明白
我觉得这个问题啊其实就是我前面其实有覆盖到啊就是音视频的开发者你从我自己的职业发展经历里面来看就知道了我前半段是其实在有些行业的然后不然才到了短视频行业就是所谓的音视频开发者啊我觉得大家应该要后退补去看看本质是什么东西就是
其实这两个行业要求的技术障击本质相通的不管游戏还是短视频啊他他本质上都是在图形炫朗都是在做这个方向东西现在从事一视频开发了有很多人都是有游戏行业的背景都是从那边来过包括我自己啊然后我还想成绩一个概念就是一视频开发里面大家直约上可能都会觉得主要是做编辑码相关的但实际上
是图形炫狼编辑是其中非常小的一部分真正研究编辑码的那些都是上榜的同学他们基本不做工程的然后编程下呢我们呢其实做的更多的是炫狼然后只是调用现成的那个编辑码模块而已中心还是在炫狼上所以刚那个问题作为音视频开发者那个后续怎么发展我觉得考虑的应该是说图形炫狼这个领域的发展签计
你应该把这些定位到一个更加通用的更加持续的一个一个基础基础方向上面去图习递宣党我觉得是一个永远不会过时的领域啊这个这个这个地方
很直接基本上可视化方向你都可以参与你比如说我们现在做的贴纪动向方案对吧你可以到其他国家还可以跟我们提交PR一些参与经济共建然后比如说像AI结合的一些特效这个可能就现在大家手上就能够看到的一些东西甚至是UI框架或者是游戏引擎这些东西你都是可以涉足的
这可能有些人就没有往这方向去想了其实你在做渲染上面的东西就是所有可见的内容这些行业的领域你都是可以转行过去了那恶地选择发展是不是这就又是一大片的一个场景了那比如说拍摄我们做到现在的让我们不玩相机了我们玩ARVR这样发展这些都是不做的场景就整体上是我觉得是非常非常广阔的大家还是要往后退一步然后看到本质是什么
明白是我的网络有问题吗是我分享完了啊可以可以好的好的对啊那我觉得其实还是确实很有价值就是其实是希望大家不要把那个路走斩了对吧对对对不要不要说自己是我觉得这几个标签什么自己是世界家开发不要不要这样自己是停开发不要这样说你可以说我做图计券了好的谢谢
我觉得受益匪浅好的那又讲的另外一点就是因为现在动格还在持续的关注技术嘛对那其实想让你分享下去比较自己你比较关注的一些技术这样的话我觉得可能对于直播间的这些开发者们比如说你觉得对他们来说也觉得比较价值的一些技术可以给大家分享一下
我其实最近都还就刚讲到职业的连续新闻我一直是在突击旋转这个领域的所以我关注的还是突击旋转这个方向的那最近有在研究一个叫Rife的RIVE的一个技术产品啊他前面有个同学在直播间里面就问了我们别去后面会不会去支持可交互性啊Rife这个产品我正在研究的他其实就是在做可交互图形的
然後這個產品據說是谷歌Skiart團隊裡面的核心演發出來參與去做的然後他們有一個在線的編輯器從零開始實現了類似AE裡面的一些時間軸動效的製作能力但是整體的使用上面肯定是不如AE的功能往上和有效率但是他們的亮點是說額外的這些機組他們做了一些可交互的一些能力整體它也是可以看出來是吸收借鑒了不少其他程度方案的設計比如像谷歌動畫裡面
經常會用到的這種多時間軸的融合能力按百分比的融合那我們現在正在研究就是如何把可交互的能力這一部分的可交互的能力與我們非常成熟的AE的這種的東銷工作流給它進行整合把兩者的優點給整合起來
所以回答直播间前面那个同学问题就是贴机会不会去增加这种可交互能力会这个是我们5.0里面就剧透一下5.0里面最重要的一个一个能力然后进行已经开始启动了然后呢另外一块呢就是还是图一旋转的我可能会比较关注就是
持续还是在关注SKR的这个项目就是谷歌的SKR项目虽然我们做了一个它的替代的一个方案但是其实核心是说给行业一个就是另外的一种选择就是包体更加轻量然后并且90%多功能和性能都是持平的那这个是一个是一个差异化一个优势但是本身谷歌的SKR的项目还是非常非常优秀的那我们最近也发现他有一些新的动作呢就是已经是准备吧
老的那一套的GPU线缆价格完全飞机到他们重新平行开发一套然后我在里面看的已经完全没有一分之二了它只针对像那个甚至是还没有标准化的那个webGPU就是webGL3.0你可以这样理解然后都都已经在里面切起来了然后我觉得作为前沿的图形圈缆的那个宽价是这个是值得研究一下那我想问一个问题是不是如果
想要去关注你比较关注的技术是不是比如说参与到这个成为这个PAG的这种开源贡献者也会更加有机会一些因为这个PAG是完全开源的就是你想成为开源贡献者就是现在马上就可以了对对对我是说就是如果去参与到里面其实能看到因为本身你也在我还在往这个项目里面去contribute的一些代码其实在这个过程中就能通过他的一些亲特性也能看到你最近比较关注的一些技术对不对
是的我再补充一点我觉得大家可能对参与开源项目之间的事情理解可能会有一些很局限其实是参与开源项目的话你在里面就不是说要写一个特别复杂的功能模块什么的甚至里面做一些文档化的工作你让那个项目能够发展得更大然后同时也在帮助你去更好地理解它内部的一些原理你可以比如说你可以把它一些东西给
研究透了然后你用你的理解把它给分享出来那去补全这个社区上面的文档化的工作也是开源项目非常重要的一部分我们自己平时也花大量的时间在写各种的那个教授文档然后让他的整个价格会更加精心然后还有就是你遇到的各种的一个bug对吧那个可能群里面有很多人在提各种的bug你其实可以去帮忙去回答这些bug那同样的你也你也基础是说你得
很了解这个项目你才知道然后甚至你拿出你把这个bug把别的问题给国家玩了你发现确实是我们的
方案裡面還可以再改進一下這個是很多的很多這種的改進的點不是說到現在就沒有什麼改進的空間了你可以給我們提交一個PR然後一步步往上面走那隨著一些那個那個小的改動慢慢的逐步上去的話你會深入到很核心的內容的開發然後慢慢就會變成這個項目裡面核心的一個開發者我覺得很多像國內的一些開發者其實在開源這件事情上面參與多了就是還是用的會多就是
整合进去他就觉得就是得我的鞋里面很关键某块才行这其实不是他是一个徐徐渐渐过程里你在这里面学你都能够获得很多的收益就是我讲的提升自己的技术你这个是你的硬碰过吗你在里面把这个直觉给他借鉴过来对这个很重要嗯明白明白所以其实还是我还是挺鼓励大家能就是参与到这个项目中去如果只能作为一个开展的贡献者的话
確實可能能更好的去關注到動格現在關注的一些新的技術或者是他的一些新的思考好的那我覺得這幾個問題其實都是關於動格本身的一些一些一些成長和思考那其實我們也還準備了另外剩下三個問題吧其實跟這個PAG本身相關的對首先第一個問題就是說想了解一下動格當時為什麼會選擇做動效工作有解決方案這樣的一個事情呢
当时是怎么想的就是那个那个快速说一下吧就是其实主要还是从需求通点的出发吧因为我们当时我从游戏行业转到短视频行业的时候发现原来十多年前就把研发跟设计打通的非常往上的这种发下去相关的工作流在移动中还是个
盲荒的状态就完全没办法相信是这种一个状态然后直接断产了整个行业都缺少完善的解决方案大家都在用写单码方式换运动效都表达了非常高的一个痛苦程度那我们当时主要的那个出发场景就是要在短视频里面去做那种各种的帖子啊可编辑的文本花字啊这些带动效的内容然后这些东西我们要是
靠用代幅码去翻译的话根本不可能完成量产刚才那一场量的要求有很高那所以当时就就就就开始就开始就开发了那个贴级的那个指法方案我我一直是这种风格哈我用一花更长的时间然后去解系统性的解决一个问题然后把它销率彻底给提上去而不是说我可能堆一下能过去把这几批的贴纸都割啊手都给他给他写了所以我们当时花了大概就是
整整六个月的时间才把第一个版本运行起来这里还是比较感谢Rodin要是如果没有一个方案已经摆在前面他把这个整个通路证明了是能够走得通的我们在三个月的时候可能就有可能有放弃掉了所以所以这还是在我们的剪板上然后把这个东西给推到更高的高度
这个就是一开始在视频编辑产业上当成人出来的贴近但是因为我们一开始解决产业也就是最复杂的那个产业键然后呢所以实现了整个的底层啊从游戏引擎那接近出发了很多的价格设计的经营业所以把它做得非常的稳固然后呢适用性也很高所以后来就逐步扩展到像Ui多号产业直播呀都是可以完全接龙使用的那现在就那个也把所有的品牌都覆盖完
所以慢慢一步步发达我也都是被这些需求推走对 还有一个问题就是这个问题另外一个问题是关于对 因为PGC开源的嘛然后其实我们有时候经常看到有一些就很多大的互联网公司他可能会讲一些方案但是呢这些方案其实可能大家问的时候可能会说也没开源就没有开源嘛所以其实很想了解一下就是
像洞哥就是比如说像当时就PG开源的一些故事吧就当时你是怎么思考的呃他是PG应该是从最开始就是一个开源的方式去运作对吧还是说我们在做了一段时间之后选择了开源嗯不是了PG就是今年才一个月份才刚开源的啊自己开发了应该已经有五年多了啊16年写的第一行呆马
但是就反正之前我们一直都是专注在内部使用就是腾讯内部项目的一个对接使用然后满足各种的一个需求然后在开源之前的时候我们基本上一把腾讯内存在动效需求相关的这个40几个应用都完整的接了一遍前面又介绍了你头部的相关的荣耀这种的游戏都已经接了然后手Q微信这种更不用说
但是内部业务使用过程中可能是因为设计师他觉得很好用之前可能用螺铁用什么还是有很多的痛点切换到这套方案上之后觉得非常的好然后我们也没有去做全船然后设计师会自发的口口传播然后就闯到外面去了最开始可能是指公司像粤文集团TM这些指公司然后他们就过来
那个要这个SDK然后因为是子公司我们都在一个系统里面其实其实就合法合理嘛就直接SDK给过去嘛就也就先给他们用了然后子公司又就往外面就传然后我们就开始收到邮件了就收到非常非常多的邮件然后就外部拥护请求这个开源了所以我们就夸了大概8年的时间就开始走这个公司的开源审核留着那会做这件事情核心也是说
這個方案我們判斷就是說因為它真確實解決了很多產品的痛點然後從用戶的強烈的這種開源訴求的一個反饋來判斷我們覺得它未來是有通用性的產業價值的那加上騰訊公司它本來也是比較鼓勵那個開源的想提升自己在產業裡面的影響力所以就就就做了這個這個開源的整個的流程申請還是挺複雜的就是整個要做那個材料脫敏什麼各方面的東西
半年把它走完了所以在今年1月份的时候正式完成了对外开源成果也相对是比较显著我们开源的时候只有内部的四十几个产品都洗了一遍都接了到现在已经最新的数据应该快到500了就是真的十几倍就是这几个月每个月多人看见数据一直在增长有新的业务不停地在使用明白所以我觉得其实
这其实是一个怎么讲的就是一个技术产品的魅力吧一个好的技术产品的魅力就是它的这个开源都不是一个主动性的开源就是别人都在你用会觉得很好用的情况下就可能大家都希望你把它放出来然后让大家一起用
所以在直播间有一个同学说我们一直在用当不是我们外传的我觉得没事了比较感谢你们外传让我们有这个动力去对外去做对对对我觉得是一个很美好的故事因为它是从确实是等于是所有的东西从就PAG这个解决发案从始至终都是一个从用户角度出发的东西可以看出来
就最先可能只是从解决我们内部的一些需求当然他发现真的是一个很好的产品之后其实会有很多其他的需求买到他这里那我觉得他开源之后肯定会有更多的需求那在这样的一个正向循环里面我觉得这个项目肯定是会越做越好好的行那我觉得回到最后一个问题吧就还是回到这个动效工作流本身那动的就是你觉得对于这个动效工作流后续它的发展前进大概是什么样子的
你可以大概給我們分析一下嗎OK啊就前面在PVT分享裡面覺得我講了一個比較有意思的細節就是行業裡面在東霞解決做東霞解決方案的幾個進品PAG、Rotel、SVGA三個產品的作者包括我自己其實都是Fresh行業出來的我們做的事情都是在復刻當年Fresh非常成熟的工作流到一種狀況上面Fresh就是歷史上面唯一的那個bar
研发跟设计工作流打通了非常往上的一个方案我可以简单分享一下我觉得它的因为我自占领行业里面沉浸了最久了我当时从社交游戏那边转到后来甚至做S95的时候那个白录影型那家公司我的我的直接老板其实是从Adobe出来的他当时就是跟着Fresh那这一块跟了十几年所以那个我对这整个整个生态包括工具链啊什么开发呀
以及它怎麼掛掉它什麼這些東西背後的三有邏輯都是非常清楚的然後我大概分享一下我覺得Fresh的發展階段主要是分為了三個就是第一個是那種突襲內容輸出大家可能還有一點印象就是年紀大一點的印象叫Sack地國就是那時候網絡不太好所以大家都在看這些死量的動畫片這個是很火的火爆一時的
那这个是它的第一个形态就是有点像我们现在A1做的东西就是输出光看的内容就是纯视频化的这种就相当于现在的视频了把视频了有点这个意思然后呢他到了第二个阶段就开始加入交互性了然后就开始往那种
把那种叫做可交互互媒体发展发展那就是那个应用场景典型的就是各种的交互广告你会在各种浏览器里面拍到在那里面看到各种可以点击的可以交互的一些一些广告出来那时候也是大景其道了这个非常非常流行这是他第二个阶段到了第三个阶段就发展成了一个非常庞大的一个一个平台整个就变成了一个开发平台打到最底分的时候就是社交游戏发展起来的时候游戏然后已经应用
很多同学可能不太了解那个时代就有点年代然后那个时候大到什么程度呢就是它的几乎每一个领域都有涉足那个游戏大家是有些印象的开心农场这种的都是基于Fashion这开发的然后应用的层面呢当时有Flex那个我不知道大家有没有听说过什么还记得吗一个叫Leash IA的Leash Internet Application
这个概念那个时候就是Wobba上面那些企业级应用它都有完善的整套的解决方案去做这些东西然后你可以部署到任何平台上然后他们后面又推出了Adobe L
那个乱烫就可以把Fresh的东西原生打包成那个作命的运行工械我们当时在做百度引擎的各种的编辑器的时候为什么我们比科幼石进品那个工具线可以铺得那么长然后能比他们少然后做的东西各种交互都比他们快就因为Fresh的开发生态的效率实在太高了然后AdobeL比他们的那个用QD用世界家去开发非常就是那个那个成本很低然后呢
LVL是历史上唯一一个你看加瓦宣传了那么多年一时编写到处运行他这辈子都没实现这件事LVL是把这个事情实现得非常彻底的我们只要是一个平台就平台上开发然后他帮你部署到Windows的Mac上面全是完全一致的体验就是这个是非常非常难得了然后他到那个后期就顶分时期的时候有那个数据我记得应该是300多万
开发者加设计师其中设计师在上出头设计师应该有220万而且这些设计师很有特点他们是计会研发因为写单码就伏尔学的行业里面我觉得可能最早的技术美术像游戏里很流行TAR技术美术就是伏尔学那个行业里面发展出来因为那个时候就是那些广告公司的那些做设计的他们都会写一点单码就那个很厉害然后想象220万的就这么弹大的
那个用户发去挂掉之后他们去哪了大部分就转到了AE上面他其实AE现在还是没有满足这些用户基础他们的对交互性的一些诉求就是他还是在发去的第一个结果就是在在做图形内容的输出就是短视频嘛就是产生视频短视频这些视频嘛对吧然后然后反正到了那个第三阶段的时候就整个发去当时的那个生态就已经非常非常庞大了他平台上面积累了大量的邮件应用然后他整个开发工具链
我再说一些可能大家更冷门一点点不清楚的就是我们现在是叫很流行的叫Wobber三本里这些技术是吧十年前那个Frasch他就有了他叫炼金树
那个他那时候就可以把世界家编译成那个发现里面的一个模块了你看是不是一样的东西就早的时候基本上什么东西都设得出来然后都很有前装性的都都做过了就是有真实的大量的业务需求再推转干这些事情那那为什么挂了呢这个得是很有意思的点就是挂的分界线你就是从巧夫斯开始出来发了一封信然后很发现开始的然后那个
背后其实我们在这个行业里面呢我们就很清楚了就瞧不是说的那些东西都不是有原因就是他说的那什么耗电耗电真实原因是什么耗电的真实原因Fresh在Apple的平台上面拿不到意见加速的解码起接口Apple为了限制他就不可以开那你播一个视频你肯定比他原生的耗电
這個根本都不是技術問題所以真正導致他掛的原因是背後的商業利益有巨大的衝突因為他當時的應用開發和遊戲開發平台已經大到一個非常恐怖的地步了如果LS那個時候喬布斯不出來把這個東西幹掉的話那個Apps多少就沒有機會發展出來你也不會在於有後續的周邊什麼他的Chocoder的開發平台他的周邊的MacBook的那個銷量啊什麼這些都是被這個帶起來的嘛但是一整個商業的帝國都是
在这个时间点呢就是乔博士做了非常英明的角色他把凡尔学在那个时间里面完全的掐死然后最终就那个分水岭之后呢也没有让凡尔学真正的就挂掉了然后耳朵笔当时还是很努力的然后说你不让我凡尔学的应用直接跑在你这个平台上没关系他们真正的投了很多的团队进去做了一件特别牛逼的事情
就把Fresh的东西重新写了一个编译器把它编成了原生的iOS的应用然后喬布斯又在干什么事情呢他改了一下上架条款转换出来的应用不能上架我这上面即使你都已经跟Fresh没关系了所以你会发现这背后的都是三叶冲突跟基础一点关系都没有再到后来整个App Store它已经渡过了危险期了就量级起来了整个生态的开发者也都起来了之后
他就把这个条款取消了然后那个时候发现还没有挂透但是差不多也差不多了然后那时候就有大量的游戏开始那个玩那个iOS参加了我不知道大家有没有玩过那个很流行的在那个游戏台湾的那个免费版的时候上面有的叫做机械名程的游戏那个那个东西就是发现去开发的他是一个品质非常高你不觉得他卡吧不觉得他耗电吧他整个品质非常高
它整个就开发了所以是有很多大量的这个应用呢如果你当时不去小布斯不去把这个东西弄掉的话那苹果上面的开发品呢应该现在就是Fresh就是就是这个种完全被被现成的这种大量的小应用直接给脏满了所以所以那个回到这个人扯得比较远就是在讲那个东校工作柳的后续发展我刚刚分享的就是有有三个发展阶段图形内容输出可交付付媒体然后开发平台
我觉得这个是一个动效工作流的正常的阶段Fedge虽然挂掉了但是它背后是因为三叶的原因然后它为我们探索出来的这整个的发展的路径是已经充分被验证过的我们现在只要跟着这个路径走一遍就行了所以这个技术的价值是很高的然后现在不管是P&G、Rotter还是SVGA他们都是只在Fedge的第一个发展阶段就是做图形内容输出因为A一直做这件事情
偏激接下来我们在明年5.0里面就会迈向第二个阶段往可交互的发展走我们会去最近大家可能也看到一些新闻就是等于跟罗比在就偏激跟AE这块有一个深度的一个一个合作我们后面会就往那个工具上面就打通可能会去扩展他在可交互能力上面的一些一些新的一些功能出来大家可以期待一下当然明年应该会往这发展那
干我的介绍其实很长的一个路线再晚下一步会不会开发平台上我们会不会去开发什么一些小游戏然后做一些应用夸平它的应用的开发这个我现在不好说我觉得放一口口吃我们先把第二个解放给做下来可能是未来可能性是有的大概就分享这么多了好的